first of all congratulations thank you
it's a big reboot now were you guys fans
of the actual 90s show Mighty Morphin
Power Rangers do you guys you and the
biggest super van yeah yeah my story
which story I have many stories well
though I didn't know it was a series
back then I didn't know about the Power
Rangers back oh really I was a fan of
the Power Rangers I guess twice now
three times over cuz my first my first
action figure was a Power Ranger I
didn't know I didn't know about the
Power Rangers my mom just bought this
action figure to stop me from crying
because she just moved me from mainland
China to Hong Kong leaving all my family
all my cousins we have a big loving
family and then so I had this action
figure with me all throughout my
childhood like in the bathtub underwater
adventures in space whatever right in
bed in space in the space in my head Oh
imaginative space right so then and then
I found out about the Power Rangers of
the show when I came when I moved to
North America to Canada and that was the
show that and and embarrassing ly enough
Pokemon was the show I ran home after
school to watch right and so I became a
fan twice over then like even jealous
evangelist fan is how you say it in
English sorry weird room where I don't
speak English very well but yes and now
I'm a fan three times over because
together we are more what's he been like
does it come with a lot of
responsibility I mean this is a show
that I mean I've re I was reading some
of the stuff and I mean all the way down
to people commenting on the suits and
this color and that color and the shades
it's like it's a huge responsibility I
think we are very aware that we're
stepping into something that's already
so established and so huge and obviously
influenced all of us and you know we
grew up interacting with the show it
made some kind of impact in our lives
and it's big shoes to fill but we're
very excited and very very proud of the
work that we put in I think the fans
would be very surprised in very high
be with the work that we did I think we
have an opportunity to kind of delve
into these characters on a on a more
layered level you know and kind of give
them a depth that maybe you know wasn't
there before so I think that's a good
opportunity for us as actors as well and
I think that's kind of what I focused on
as well in fact I kind of made a
conscious decision not to not to watch
and study the older shows and just so I
had kind of a blank canvas now of course
I'm like you know delving in but yeah
it's like for me so I'm from write
Jacksonville Florida
aka Duval County it's like everybody in
my neighborhood in across like our city
knows we're powering just ears right so
when I first book the part I realized
that oh crap it's not just you know just
the name of Billy that I'm putting on
it's like okay put your whole everybody
in your city is looking for you to make
this part and do it just this right so
all my friends weren't like
congratulations RJ this is so exciting
congratulations they were like look
don't mess this up I was like oh okay so
no good stuff no no we're not gonna say
congratulations until we see the movie
so that's like one of those things where
I'm like all right I feel like yeah it's
on it's all I can crush Billy's crushed
it he crushed it and but we all Krusty's
carry the Blue Ranger is that your yeah
how do you did the what made you think
this is crazy
your responsibility to wear blue no I
actually love blue I'll give you look at
my closet you would think that I'm a
confused gang member it's crazy so I got
get red on one side doing the other side
but I like them both a lot my picture
color did you pick your ranger you
picked your coat no get a chance to pick
us that's what it's like how the coins
find us it's so cool that the casting
actually found us because well I found
out when I first arrived in Vancouver
was nay had originated audition for the
role of Trini and she ended up being the
pink ranger and yellow since I was very
very young has always been my favorite
color and that's the color that chose me
so it's crazy how it all kind of just
worked itself out and I feel like in
real life we all do have a little bit of
our characters characteristics in us
and we kind of were able to play and
dabble into that what's it like when you
hear someone like Bryan Cranston signed
on mate it was pretty incredible
I mean you you're going through the
whole process we had somebody else
reading his role for a few weeks and he
sort of get a sense of like Zordon and
I've said this before but it's like
place that kind of patriarchal role and
you're sort of getting an idea and then
it's like Bryan Cranston and you're like
wow this you know this person I've been
watching on TV since I was little and
Malcolm in the middle and then Breaking
Bad and then you know and then finding
out that he had something to do with the
original show which I had no idea you
know RJ's character Billy Cranston is
the Cranston's coming in and and I had
no idea yeah Billy Cranston
yeah Cranston he's like Billy's dad are
there are no Easter eggs in this movie
at all for the old fans the pictures
been circulating of Elizabeth Banks with
her hands around your neck that's been
all over the place yeah it was so cool
to see um I was obviously much cooler to
actually live it uh it was such a crazy
process from going into sweats blocking
out the scene just her eye and Dean and
then going into the real thing and
literally smashing each other against
the walls and I was sore the next day I
had scratches on my neck and it was so
good so so good wasn't apologizing oh
yeah I mean we had so much fun you know
it's kind of awkward too with all the
stunts and stuff you're hanging around
in a harness like a pinata so we were
very very playful and just having a lot
of fun what's it like putting on a
different hat for you going from like
being a performer a singer-songwriter to
then getting a chance to do some acting
it's a lot of fun it's very inspiring um
you know it's kind of starting from the
ground up again on the music side it's
like this freedom creative freedom to do
whatever I want but in this it's doing
what's right for my character and making
decisions for for a whole other person
and you know sometimes it may not be
what Becky G wants to do and that was so
fun for me because Trudy is actually the
total opposite of me in real life I'm
such a glam girl and she's the total not
that
so it was really fun and really cool I
had a lot of amazing actors to look up
to and learn from around me so can you
or can you not play Becky G on set are
you left uh I don't know I mean I am Who
I am so unsaid I was we would sing and
be goofy and whatever but when it was
time to really get into it I think I did
really want separated into two people um
yeah what about the bond for you guys
cuz I mean it seems like you guys are
like a little family mortal enemies yeah
when did you first realize you didn't
like anyone your work oh yes I think
moment when Becky stole my cookies when
they all showed up and we met for the
before the first table read actually for
the first time and then I realized that
they're all better-looking than me and I
was going on well we all know that's not
true this is not gonna work this is not
radio early human being I did
it makes us mad in the gym cuz every
time Looney takes his shirt off it's
just like alright put the weights down
let's go home I don't know why no but
obviously seriously the first day before
before the actual table read the big
table read with all those two executives
we got together um taker said that we
get together and and read the script
ourselves so we have this table read I'm
just alone at RJ's house which became
like headquarters Power Rangers
unofficially and then we had this table
read where we just we had a lot of fun
and then there was laughs and then there
was tears and then there was tears
someone was crying
who's the soft one of the group who's
the first one in tears
was me I was crying passionate scrit was
so beautiful the story was amazing and
these guys just moved me their
performances every turn I was just until
that day we have a bond we all had our
moments on set you know in terms that's
the whole point and we all encourage
each other yeah we all encourage each
other is we have we've all kind of
because you see all that you know you go
through all the ups and downs and it's a
long shoot it's four months it's very
physical and so yeah we had to we had to
keep each other going and we did we got
through with food related activities
like if the last donor was gone from
crabs desert oh I had a fit
I was upset especially the ones with the
jelly in the middle was it like yeah
it's probably it's been said before but
what you see on screen by the end of the
film that's the same off-screen the
relationship that that grows and changes
and we share experiences that's exactly
what happened in real life like we've
been saying I think - yes yeah it was
just being and
the friendship is what you see on screen
that's uh that's
yup you guys could almost just interview
each other it's amazing your publicist
your postman over there okay wrap it up
I say